my job is to to find out what makes
people laugh and to make them laugh as
big as possible long time comedian
Gallagher has died he was 76 years old I
do the talking for everybody I think
what I say in my jokes is what
everybody's thinking and that's why they
applaud at the end according to reports
the performer real name Lee Anthony
Gallagher died on Friday while in
Hospice Care in Palm Springs California
he survived by his son Barnaby and
daughter Amy easy spent time with them
at his home back in the early 80s you
want me to jump too
put on my thinking hat what would be
funny
best known for his prop comedy
Gallagher's career spanned decades oh
here's a good one hitting it big with
his trademark of Smashing objects on
stage most notably watermelons
I think that this job is so social
so family oriented to get up in front of
everybody and talk is you've got to know
what everybody's thinking and who you
might offend it's a very tough job being
out on the limb finding out how far
Society will let you go the often
controversial comic filmed 17 comedy
specials and was a go-to TV guest star
here he is legendary performer and
comedian please welcome
Gallagher so we've got that Sunday for
you
yeah if this whole tradition of Comedy
was not together already I couldn't
believe that people would pay to go and
sit in a group in a theater and hear a
guy say things that made you laugh isn't
it a strange
whole thing
[Music]